hi reject nation I'm Greg Alba
and I am Ashley yes you are and so weird
sitting on this side I can never tell a
force directly Center for the camera we
are yeah right here yeah hey Ashley do
you like Family Guy
I love Family Guy yes we're gonna try
it's a life challenge is so bad so many
reactors are covering this and I said
well I don't want to be left behind
let's do more of them and it's all
Family Guy it's only Family Guy okay
let's put your headphones on do not
laugh nope it's cheating if you what
about smiling that's fine it's just if
noise comes out tomorrow you get over
some noise comes out video he's got a
big smile on your face there you go
giggling woo before we start this
alright
imagine imagine your mother shooting you
all she's got dark
all right I'm ready who's this with the
his abs I believe that's Ryan Reynolds
let's start this cuz I've seen this
episode
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you call a few days in advance to give
me time to get the house clean maybe you
bring a blazer so we could go to a wider
range of restaurants you're losing right
now you're making a lot of noise
[Music]
[Music]
internet check tissues check lotion
check okay let's go so that I could feel
it
[Applause]
Peter how did you do it I tell you Bob I
just got my car and drove it and when
there was a guy in my way I killed him I
can talk I'm just sitting out here in
the open
my car
it's a
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
that was just more disturbing
blinds
[Music]
let it out do it laughs that's a great
invention
I'm sure there's two sides to this show
me one way which I heard it's a
cliffhanger
[Laughter]
I remember it was like season 1 or 2
whenever that bit happened man I kept
laughing through my nose okay yeah yeah
that should count I heard yours you
girls I was I've never seen or I don't
remember this pac-man bit right here
haven't seen though the bull riding one
is really funny I lost it on that one
and I lost it on the mo where they're
doing that one yes The Electric Company
parody the devil yeah that was a funny
one one nipple
Brian not having hair that's there's
just there's someone scary I think I
remember that episode I think Peters is
constantly pranking Brian is constantly
getting naked well there's a lot of
family guides there is yeah I like the
blind to do because I might totally do
that I can relate to this problem some
of my favorite family got bits are the
ones that are so close to reality and
there's this something kind of funny
about watching an animated thing yeah
thank you fun of something that's so
real and I like to tell like there was
voices just so subtly like yeah yeah
like just some input but it's like it's
so like in the background because blinds
are the most complicated things to get
down you know this Yankee device why
isn't that real maybe it is I should
google that seems like a great invention
after this episode it probably was a
real thing probably a hundred percent
let's see let's see
yank it a Yankee Yankee the Yankee
device isn't real people darn I'm sorry
to disappoint
the hoarding here's domestic violence is
that's sad but funny that's one of the
Family Guy bits that has always stuck
with me really yeah it's just like
radial laugh cuz that's a bit that if
people haven't seen a make sure frame is
like a peanut yeah
this is so disturbing to me it's the
definition of like a good Family Guy
joke oh that's so edgy because you're
just hearing like what sounds like a
real domestic life I'm sure there's two
sides of the story
how people really reacted stuff like
that yeah that terms of like realism to
like that joke of I hit a deer then you
just really you know argument about not
why huge changes sure you laughed on the
one where he dropped Brian tail with a
cat
I didn't burst out laughing does that
count can you guys come and does it
count if I'm laughing through my nose
sometimes I can't hear it
I can't hear from laughing through my
nose I mean obvious there should be a
obviously but it's the point of point if
we're not keep pointing I think that I
did better than what I usually do yeah
you sure I think I did like in life like
when we're having a conversation I
really tried to yes you did great ash
I'm really proud of you thank you you uh
probably the proudest moment in all your
career thanks I'm gonna put on my resume
I can't wait to see this house today try
not to laugh at the real region wow what
a great video you got the park you got
I'm sure I'll do another one of these
these are fun he was trying to Isis I
don't really do because they're usually
boring well usually it's like these are
pretty easy family guys like hard I get
why there's a lot of people doing them
because Family Guy is actually pretty
hard to not laugh at alright guys well
thanks for tuning in you could subscribe
to the reject nation hey quick
notification bells check out Ashley ed
nur on Instagram where she dresses
appropriately he perverts and
what do you think I never go there I
miss Instagram and guys can also check
us out on faith we got plenty of [ __ ]
over there see you guys